hey guys Jess and Dan here we're not
Joey but we are here to do an unboxing
for you or more accurately it's a nun
bagging because we're gonna be getting
into the Blizzcon goodie bag which
everyone can get their hands on this
year so all the attendees and it'll also
be available online if you want to pick
it up so to figure out whether you want
to pick it up let's go through the
interior there it is first of all you
got this sweet backpack
you may notice this this is this odd
section on the front of the bag it's
velcro okay and that is gonna factor in
light out once we get inside let's find
out what's in here pull this one down
okay
all right let's go for that here's the
first thing we've got we've got a badge
icon pack so it looks like I assume
these are gonna be what you attach to
the velcro on your back there shall we
find out yes let's open the very
exciting oh yeah okay so they're all
velcro cool so looks like Starcraft
Hostin overwatch this one let's stick
them on
obviously overwatch guys front center
and then yeah but I can go on top this
one can it's actually upside down so
it's from my mom and then that was
pretty sweet
I mean it's a definitely an easier way
of fixing patches and sewing them on
yeah definitely there's that to that
very cool um what's up next
living next we have grab something out
of the back of this one now we'll keep
it one tool at the end forget let's get
all the little stuff out of the way oh
here we go this is what I'm really
excited about
or was it pens are you love pins for
Blizzard collectible pins and there's
our ten characters okay I need to know
what they are okay because the suspense
is killing me
what do we got what do you got we got
there's only one pin right I'm confused
Oh series falls you see what happened
there was I misread the packet and
thought there were four pins in there
whereas in fact it's series for impact
there's only one well that's pretty cool
and for those who want to know how it
looks on a sweet denim jacket it's
pretty good you wouldn't put that on the
front of your obviously this is just for
the velcro bit oh yeah let's give it a
pull out okay you want to go next all
right yeah I'm okay good all right so
what we've got is a cute but deadly
series 304 tradition figure rain sweep
so just say so it looks like they've got
a bunch of different characters
including genji break down the fray
daiva Lucy are all your favorites mhm
there's probably some barrels um but
basically there's a whole bunch of
different ones um and this does appear
to be another blind boxer
let's see which one away you got I'll
get someone good Lucia doesn't have
enough representation in collectibles I
feel really being the best at what
character I mean at least he's on there
they must be overwatch characters that
aren't on there right doesn't look like
um there's no soldier don't piss you
symmetric
next time okay so we're at a little
aluminum packet how do we get Oh soldier
sweet oh wait there is important he
comes with his little gun in his Lodge
head and little legs know I'm liking the
game and a stand for you to when it was
let's put him on his stick yeah good
idea
so once he's pretty awesome he's got
some kind of cool skin he does have he
does appear to have a scan on all right
this is all really cool well sweet sorry
soldier fun he can uh I think we're up
to the last thing now this is the is the
last one
that's my last one is a overwatch
backpack doing I did not know what that
was um again blind pack well looks like
you can get Zenyatta in here so that
could be good I really like Zenyatta who
did we get Oh what everyone's favorite
Gila oh my gosh cute as hell little
demon skin and so you can pop that on
your backpack it's just a [ __ ] how do
we hope these are
the dangle you put it on that yeah I
don't know I don't know I don't jangle
things on my back okay I'd be too afraid
someone would steal this on the trail
it's kids up their skins instead of
they're like regular yeah they're like
default that is cool so they go that's
what you can get if you go if you got a
bus con this [ __ ] can get a goody bag so
thanks again to Blizzard for sending
that over you can subscribe for more
unboxings and more videos from us here
at GameSpot but yeah and also yeah make
sure you check out the gear stores
before that interests you you can
actually get a upgrade which will get
you more collectibles and more stuff so
you could look into doing that if you're
if you're interested in all this product
we're gonna go I'm gonna go take this
backpack around town and see how I can
see how it goes see if anyone steals it
what's this
[Applause]